es geht und es ist nötig landwirtschaft
ohne tiere statt massentierhaltung und
mega stellen also bauernhöfe die
komplett dir frei sind
erste projekte zeigen jetzt tatsächlich
erfolgen wie das funktioniert und ob das
tatsächlich eine lösung für eine gesunde
und zukunftsfähige ernährung ist jetzt
den klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
massentierhaltung mit mega stellen
tiertransporten und oft unkontrollierter
antibiotika vergabe hat nichts mit dem
bauernhof in öl zu tun dass manche
vielleicht noch so im kopf haben von
wegen glückliche kühe und einer großen
grünen wiese und hühnern die im dreck
scharen um mal eben nach lust und laune
ein ei legen stattdessen masthähnchen
die zu zehntausenden in großen allen
gestopft werden schweine die in ihrem
ganzen leben kein tageslicht gesehen
haben und kühe mit entzündeten heute an
allesamt voll gestopft mit antibiotika
so schreibt die heinrich böll stiftung
in ihrem fleisch atlas von 2016 zitat
die massentierhaltung auf engstem raum
wirkt sich negativ auf die tiere aber
auch auf die umwelt aus so tragen
gewaltige mengen an gülle und der
ammonit ausstoß der anlagen dazu beiden
biotope grundwasser seen flüsse und
küstengewässer permanent mit nitrat zu
übertönen
die landwirtschaft ist wirklich zu einem
großen umweltverschmutzer geworden und
das ist wirklich pervers schlimm genug
doch das ganze hat zudem auch noch
weitreichende folgen für das klima und
auch für uns die verbraucher die
organisation foodwatch hat dazu einige
studien analysiert und das ergebnis ist
schlimm jedes vierte tierischen produkt
stammt von einem kranken tier und das
sind dann am ende natürlich produkte die
für uns nicht gesund sind doch die
massentierhaltung ist ein riesiges
geschäft um bei der produktion für den
weltweiten export mithalten zu können
haben sich die meisten landwirte
inzwischen auf eine einzige tierart
spezialisieren einige wenige betriebe
wachsen rasant während im letzten
jahrzehnt viele bauernhöfe die
tierhaltung aufgegeben haben das
paradoxe daran nach rechnung der
heinrich böll stiftung hat die
bundesweite fleischproduktion dennoch um
etwa die hälfte zugenommen
trotzdem steigt auch der anteil der
vegetarier in deutschland laut der
statista gmbh gibt es im jahr 2017 in
der deutschsprachigen bevölkerung ab 14
jahren rund 5,7 millionen personen die
sich selbst als vegetarier bezeichnen
würden bzw
personen die weitgehend auf fleisch
verzichten 2013 waren es noch 5,3
millionen menschen die
interessenvertretung für vegetarier und
veganer webo geht sogar von rund acht
millionen vegetarier
in deutschland aus das sind etwa 10 der
bevölkerung laut einer befragung eines
marktforschungsinstitutes ernähren sich
aktuell 1,3 millionen menschen rein
pflanzlich also vegan und das kommt
natürlich dem tierschutz zugute doch was
viele nicht wissen auch der obst-
gemüse- und getreideanbau ist eng mit
der wirtschaft verknüpft der nährstoffe
wie phosphor oder stickstoff werden den
boden nach der ernte nicht nur in form
von mist oder dummen wieder zugeführt
auch abfallprodukte aus der tierhaltung
wie blut und knochenmehl werden als
organischer zusatz dünger eingesetzt
selbst einige bio verbände erlauben das
denn was viele nicht wissen die
zertifizierung vegan oder vegetarisch
bezieht sich nicht auf die produktion
sondern auf das lebensmittelrecht das
ist schon ziemlich perfide der essen wir
vegane produkte dort die ernähren sich
von tierischen produkten igitt warum
gegensatz zu land wirtschaftsverbänden
gibt es mittlerweile einige landwirte
die ihre arbeit komplett wie bio vegan
betreiben sie nutzen keine tiere oder
tierischen produkte und konzentrieren
sich voll und ganz auf den pflanzenanbau
hier reihen sich kartoffeln salate und
kohlstatt kühen und schweinen gibt es
hier nur noch gemüsefelder die auch ohne
tierischen dünger aus kommen dass diese
idee funktionieren kann zeigen
mittlerweile rund 80 kleinbäuerlichen
betriebe in griechenland die ihre
produkte mittlerweile nach ganz europa
exportieren acker wirtschaften und
viehwirtschaft werden hier traditionell
getrennt betrieben und so wissen die
bahn bereits seit generationen die
landwirtschaft ohne tiere funktioniert
in deutschland wurde vor kurzem der bio
zyklisch vegane verein gegründet wo
unter anderem landwirte aus der pfalz
organisiert sind die auf vegane art und
weise gemüse und obst produzieren der
verein hat sich den ausbau dieser idee
in ganz deutschland auf die fahne
geschrieben
auf der web seite fordert er eine
kreislauf orientierte vegan
ausgerichtete form des ökologischen
landbaus durch einführung der bio
zyklisch veganen prinzipien in allen
bereichen der land- und
ernährungswirtschaft umwelt natur und
klimaschutz tierethik gesundheit und
welternährung ohne rückgriff auf die
landwirtschaftliche tierhaltung haben
dabei besondere bedeutung
zitat ende
die albert schweitzer stiftung sieht
genau dies als einen lösungsansatz um
auf ethische art und weise einige
unserer ernährungs und agra probleme zu
lösen
denn man darf nicht vergessen für die
produktion von fleisch müssen unmengen
mehr an pflanzen angebaut werden als
wenn wir sie direkt essen würden zurück
zur bio veganen landwirtschaft die es in
deutschland bereits vereinzelt gibt hier
werden pro hof durchaus 30 bis 40
verschiedene sorten gemüse angebaut
teilstücke der felder wachsen wild und
bieten schutz und nahrung für nützlinge
wie bienen oder schmetterlinge
so entsteht ein natürliches
gleichgewicht zu dem schützen sie auf
natürliche art und weise vor schäden
durch mögen schnecken oder läuse auf
pestizide und künstlichen dünger dagegen
wird verzichtet das einzige was an die
pflanzen kommt ist bio veganer dünger
wie beispielsweise kompostiert des
klägers keine frage
die pflanzen wachsen so natürlich nicht
annähernd so schnell wie die die
konventionelle angebaut werden doch die
meisten dieser landwirte sehen den
bioanbau als einzige option die aktuelle
agrarpolitik bezeichnen sie als
verheerend für tiere verbraucher und
umwelt und dieser stunde anbau ist auch
im moment das einzige mittel gegen den
dramatischen schwund an insekten über
den wir hier des öfteren berichtet
hatten der gefährdet nämlich die gesamte
versorgung mit nahrungsmitteln und damit
die existenz der menschheit und fest
steht auch so viel fleisch wie viele von
uns essen muss aus gesundheitlichen
gründen gar nicht sein im gegenteil wenn
wir uns in deutschland an die empfehlung
der deutschen gesellschaft für ernährung
halten würden würde dies den
bundesweiten fleischkonsum um die hälfte
reduzieren es gibt berechnungen nach
denen dadurch fast ein viertel der
landwirtschaftlichen nutzfläche
freigesetzt würde
die große frage könnte man die weiter
wachsende weltbevölkerung mit tier
freier landwirtschaft vegan ernähren
dazu der agraringenieur daniel
mitgründer des bio vegan netzwerks in
deutschland zitat die höfe die heute
schon bio vegan produzieren haben aber
in hinblick auf wirtschaftlichkeit und
ressourcenverbrauch eine durchweg
positive bilanz aufzuweisen die bio
vegan landwirt jedenfalls sind durchweg
optimistisch auch was den minderertrag
im vergleich zu ihrem konventionell
arbeitenden kollegen
angehen denn was man nicht vergessen
darf die tiere sind ein zwischen glied
der nahrungskette produkte vom feld
gehen in der bio vegan landwirtschaft
eben nicht den umweg über das tier
sondern werden direkt für die
menschliche ernährung benutzt macht auch
sinn wenn man bedenkt dass bei der
herstellung einer tierischen kalorie
etwa 7 pflanzliche kalorien benötigt
werden und das ist an menge noch mal
mehr
aber das hat man ja gerade es ist
wirklich ein riesiger energieverlust
doch und bio veganen landwirtschaft
weiter nach vorne zu bringen braucht es
viele faktoren zunächst einmal eine
politik die entsprechende
rahmenbedingungen schafft und zudem auch
ein umdenken in der gesellschaft nur
dann haben solche lösungsansatz für eine
zukunftsfähige gesunde ernährung auch
eine chance es ist also zeit zum handeln
und das könnt ihr jetzt und das schreibt
das generation manifest damit die
zukunft besser wird und nicht schlechter
harald lesch ist dabei melis ali annette
frier eckart von hirschhausen ich bin
dabei und so weiter und so fort
hier ist der link unbedingt mitmachen
ich zähle auf euch und tier geht es
weiter mit das große sterben der
insekten
das ist wirklich ziemlich dramatisch und
ansonsten bis dann bleib dran